[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je remarque beaucoup plus qu'au jour le
jour je parle un petit peu plus avec le
qu'avant
Léa Alary Baudouin à 20 ans et elle
vient d'entreprendre des études en
gestion à l'Université Concordia à
Montréal pour des raisons de prestige et
d'opportunités c'est vraiment une école
qui est reconnue à l'international fait
qu'il y avait ce côté-là qui m'a tirait
puis évidemment aussi le fait que la
langue des affaires c'est l'anglais
comme des milliers de jeunes Québécois
de langue maternelles françaises léa a
choisi de faire ses études supérieures
en anglais quand j'étudie je prends mes
notes en anglais ce que avant je faisais
pas évidemment et que je dirais de plus
en plus mes très pensés vont se faire en
anglais parce que c'est la terminologie
que j'utilise depuis 2001 il a
recensement de 2001 le nouveau
millénaire il y a une nouvelle donne on
dirait le poids du français que ce soit
la langue maternelle ou la langue
d'usage recule et le poids de l'anglais
avance
[Musique]
nous-mêmes on n'est pas
sensible à la protection de notre langue
commune notre langue officielle
ça part mal oui c'est préoccupant le
poids démographique des francophones a
diminué partout au Québec surtout à
Montréal Laval et en Outaouais oui il a
chuté de près de 3% en 5 ans les
chiffres sont assez simples et le taux
d'assimilation soit le transfert
linguistique du français vers l'anglais
et de 5% chez les jeunes montréalais ce
qui représente près de 40000 personnes
au Québec c'est encore naissant ce
mouvement dans les situations des
francophones si on le laisse aller si on
ne modifie pas radicalement les règles
de jeu ça va se renforcer il y a
beaucoup de jeunes francophones à
Concordia de ce que j'ai vu jusqu'à
présent peut-être un 20% quand on se
rend compte on va tout le temps des au
lieu d'asper bonjour fait que c'est
difficile de savoir en moins qu'on les
écoute bien qu'on essaie de déchiffrer
un petit accent
la grande attractivité de l'anglais pour
les jeunes francophones se reflètent
aussi au niveau collégial que moi je
veux maman aller dans un domaine de
journaliste et de programmer
international donc qui ça me semblait
comme un une très bonne décision à faire
d'avoir cette base là parce que toute
mon éducation a été fait en français si
j'étudiants en anglais j'ai plus une
grande chance d'évoluer dans le domaine
le nouveau étudié en droit et peut-être
travailler en français l'autre a choisi
l'histoire et projette de travailler en
anglais les deux admettent que leur
univers est devenu très anglophone très
américain que ça soit de la musique des
films
tout vraiment tout c'est
je pense que c'est vraiment universel
aussi mais si je peux rajouter à ça
c'est le rendu la langue internationale
parce qu'elle est facile à apprendre
fait que je pense que
l'influence des États-Unis que sur le
monde fait en sorte que l'anglais sera
rendu plus facile on s'accommande
vraiment plus avec l'anglais
si Marilou Alary candidate du Bloc
québécois aux dernières élections
fédérales aurait préféré que sa fille
choisisse d'étudier en français
difficile donc pour cette maman de
blâmer toute une génération puisque sa
propre fille participe à cette
transformation je suis en train
d'apprendre de plusieurs personnes qui
viennent de partout dans le monde
je le vois pas comme si c'était en train
de nuire à la culture québécoise plutôt
que peut-être l'enrichir après ça ça
dépend à ce que les jeunes qui vont dans
les universités anglophones décident
d'apprécier dans leur vie personnelle à
eux de faire un
du revirement puis de poursuivre
vraiment en anglais l'immigration est au
coeur du débat les nouveaux arrivants
peuvent jouer un rôle dans le maintien
de la culture francophone selon la
plupart des experts un rôle tout de même
limité selon celui-ci l'immigration
francisable disons plus facilement
francisable oui mais ça réglera pas le
problème de l'anglisation des deux
souches parce que l'anglais gagne sur
les deux plans il est plus fort pour le
ce que le français dans son pouvoir
d'attraction pouvoir d'assimilation
auprès des halophones et il est plus
fort dans le français dans les échanges
entre le français et l'anglais
le café ça fait plaisir c'est sûr que là
il y a comme un peu une contradiction
dans mon intérieur parce que je
participe plus à la culture anglophone
[Musique]